how do you think making while I got
wasted helped you to move forward I
think so while I got ways is my first
feature so to be moving forward on after
it how does it help me move forward I
think it's it's it's kind of amazing and
I try to explain this to people but
until you've done a feature people don't
believe you can do a feature because so
many people have failed doing a feature
so just a lot more doors open up in a
way you know people know that you've
done it and if it's at least half-decent
they think you can do it again you know
and actually I think I read something
that 99% of filmmakers make their first
feature they never make a feature again
so that's how many people try to do this
and go I don't want to do that again
this is horrible you know because you
have to really love thumb that want to
do it because it is so hard you know
like I said earlier it's like two three
hours a night I slept on Wally
and how many emergencies that would
happen or whatever and everything's
comes back on me so if you don't like to
be a leader you're not gonna like being
a film director you know you have to
manage egos you have to manage you have
to keep you cool under all circumstances
and at the same time make the right
decisions you don't want to put anybody
in danger you don't want to you know
your movies important but we're making a
movie we're not curing cancer so let's
not endanger anybody or do anything
that's unsafe and after you've done your
first feature it's just a totally
different respect you get from people
and opportunities open up way more
because now you're a real filmmaker
really I mean everybody kind of looks at
you like an amateur when you're making
short films but after you made a feature
you you're in the pros
I mean you are you're competing once you
make a feature you're competing with the
Avengers you're competing with all these
other movies there's no scale of like oh
that movie
no you're competing with them all
because the audience on Amazon can
choose Avengers that they can choose
while he got wasted you know so you're
competing with everybody and that's why
I take it easy on myself because you
know I didn't have
five hundred million dollars to make a
movie if we had 70 grand so the fact
that I'm even competing with these
movies and some people are watching my
movie I'm thrilled because there's so
much content out there right now to
watch so but you learn you know you
learn and opportunities they just open
up they open up and you don't know where
they're gonna come from after you've
done your first feature so you just got
to do it you got to do it
you gotta take the chance you got to
learn you got to fall in your face and
you got to go do it even if it never
sees the light of day at least you did
it do it again
you